La compassion.
À quoi est-ce que ça ressemble?
Venez avec moi au 915 rue Bloodworth Sud
à Raleigh, Caroline du Nord, où j'ai grandi.
Si vous venez, vous nous verrez, le soir,
à la table préparée pour dix, même si certains sièges étaient vides.
Au moment où le diner était servi,
vu que ma maman a eu huit enfants,
des fois elle disait qu'elle ne pouvait pas savoir qui était qui et où ils étaient.
Avant qu'on puisse manger, elle demandait,
"Est-ce que tous les enfants sont là?"
Et si quelqu'un manquait,
on devait prendre l'assiette de cette personne, la mettre dans le four,
et alors nous pouvions dire le bénédicité, et nous pouvions manger.
Aussi, pendant qu'on était à la table,
il y avait un rituel dans la famille,
quand quelque chose de particulier était arrivé à l'un de nous,
que ça soit maman qui ait été élue présidente de la PTA,
ou que papa ait eu une affectation à notre collège,
ou que quelqu'un ait gagné le concours de talent de jabberwocky,
le rituel de la famille était que, une fois que l'annonce avait été faite,
on devait prendre 5, 10 minutes pour célébrer cette personne,
c'est à dire, en faire toute une histoire concernant celui qui a été honoré d'une quelconque manière,
car quand une personne est honorée, tout le monde l'est.
Nous devions aussi donner des nouvelles des membres de la famille étendue que nous avions visités,
c'est à dire, les malades et
les vieux restés chez eux.
Ma tâche était, au moins une fois par semaine, de rendre visite à Mère Lassiter
qui vivait dans East Street,
Mère Williamson qui vivait sur Bledsoe Avenue,
et Mère Lathers qui vivait dans Oberlin Road.
Pourquoi? Car elles étaient vielles et infirmes.
Nous devions allez les voir au cas où elles auraient besoin de quelque chose.
Car ma mère disait, "être une famille, c'est partager et s'occuper les uns des autres.
Ils sont notre famille."
Et, bien entendu, des fois il y avait un bonus pour y avoir été.
Elles offraient des bonbons ou de l'argent.
Ma mère disait, "Si elles demandent ce que ça coute d'aller faire les courses pour elles,
vous devez toujours dire, 'Rien.'
Si elles insistent, répondez, 'Ce que vous voulez bien me donner.'"
C'était comme ça que ça se passait autour de la table.
En fait, elle précisait que si nous faisions ça,
on aurait pas seulement la joie de recevoir de la gratitude
des membres de la famille étendue,
mais elle disait, "Même Dieu va sourire, et quand Dieu souris,
il y a de la paix, de la justice, et de la joie."
Donc, à la table au 915, j'ai appris quelque chose sur la compassion.
Bien entendu, c'était une famille croyante,
donc nous devions y ajouter Dieu.
Et donc, je me suis mis à penser à la maman éternelle, la maman éternelle,
qui se demande toujours: Est ce que tous les enfants sont là?
Et si nous nous sommes occupés et avons partagé fidèlement,
on avait alors le sentiment que la justice et la paix avait une chance dans le monde.
En fait, ce n'était pas toujours merveilleux autour de la table.
Laissez moi expliquer un point sur lequel on a pas particulièrement brillé.
C'était Noël, et dans notre famille, oh quelle matinée!
Le matin de Noël, où nous ouvrions nos cadeaux,
où nous avions des prières particulières, et où nous jouions du piano,
où nous chantions des chants de Noël. C'était un moment très intime.
En fait, vous pouviez venir sous le sapin prendre vos cadeaux et vous préparez à chanter,
et ensuite vous préparez pour le petit déjeuner sans même prendre un bain ou vous habillez,
sauf que papa a tout fait foiré.
Il y avait un membre de son équipe qui n'avait pas d'endroit où aller
pour célébrer ce Noël en particulier.
Et papa a amené Elder Revels à la fête de Noël familiale.
On a pensé qu'il devait être complètement fou.
C'était notre occasion. Un moment intime.
C'est quand nous pouvions vraiment être nous mêmes,
et là nous avions ce frère ennuyeux,
avec sa chemise et sa cravate, alors qu'on était encore en pyjama.
Pourquoi est ce que papa avait amené Elder Revels?
N'importe quel autre moment, mais pas à la fête de Noël.
Alors maman nous a entendu est a dit,
"En fait, vous savez quoi? La vraie nature de cette fête,
c'est que c'est le moment d'étendre notre cercle d'amour.
C'est à ça que sert cette fête.
C'est le moment de faire de la place, de partager les joies de la vie dans une communauté aimante."
Donc, on l'a fermé.
(Rires)
En grandissant au 915, la compassion n'était pas à débattre,
c'était notre façon de vivre ensemble.
On est des frères et des sœurs unis ensemble.
Et, comme Chief Seattle a dit, "On ne fait pas tourner la toile de la vie.
On est tous des fils dessus.
Et peut importe ce que nous faisons à la toile, nous nous le faisons à nous même."
Ça c'est la compassion.
Donc, laissez moi vous dire que je vois le monde plutôt de cette façon.
Je vois des images, et je me dit, "Là, ça c'est de la compassion."
Un champ de grain récolté avec du grain sur les cotés
qui me fait pensé à la tradition hébraïque
que vous pouvez en fait recolté,
mais que vous devez toujours en laisser un peu sur les cotés
juste au cas où il y ait quelqu'un qui n'en n'ait pas
une part suffisante pour bien se nourrir.
Ça c'est une image de compassion.
-- Ça réchauffe toujours mon cœur --
une image de Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
marchant bras dessus, bras dessous avec Andy Young et Rabbi Heschel
et peut être Thich Nhat Hanh, et quelques autres saints rassemblés,
marchant sur le pont qui va vers Selma.
Une simple photographie.
Bras dessus, bras dessous pour la lutte.
Souffrant ensemble pour un espoir commun afin que nous puissions être des frères et sœurs
sans les accidents de notre naissance ou ethnicité
qui corrompent le sens de l'égalité des êtres.
Alors, voici une autre image. Voilà, celle là. J'aime vraiment cette image.
Quand Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. a été assassiné,
ce jour, tout le monde dans ma communauté a été bouleversé.
Vous aviez des émeutes dans tout le pays.
Bobby Kennedy avait prévu d'apporter un message à Indianapolis.
Voici l'image. Ils ont dit,
"ça va être trop instable pour que vous puissiez y aller."
Il a insisté, "Je dois y aller."
Donc, assis sur un camion,
les anciens de la communauté,
et Bobby se sont levé et ont dit aux gens,
"J'ai de mauvaises nouvelles pour vous.
Certains d'entre vous n'ont peut être pas entendu que le Dr. King a été assassiné,
et je sais que vous êtes en colère,
je sais que vous aimeriez presque avoir l'opportunité
de pouvoir vous venger, mais,
il a dit, "ce que je veux vraiment que vous sachiez, c'est que je sais ce que vous ressentez.
Car j'ai eu quelqu'un qui m'est cher qui m'a été arraché.
Je sais ce que vous ressentez."
Et il a dit, "J'espère que vous aurez le courage de faire ce que j'ai fait.
J'ai permis à ma colère, mon amertume, et mon chagrin de s'apaiser pendant un moment,
et ensuite j'ai pris la décision que j'allais créer un monde différent,
et nous pouvons faire ça ensemble."
Ça c'est une image. De la compassion? Je pense que j'en vois.
Je l'ai vu quand le Dalai Lama est venu à l'église de Riverside pendant que j'étais pasteur,
il a invité les représentants de chaque religion du monde.
Il leurs a demandé de nous donner un message,
et ils ont tous lu dans leurs propre langue la même affirmation,
et ça c'était une version de la règle d'or.
"Ce que vous aimeriez qu'on vous fasse,
faites le aux autres."
Ils étaient 12 dans leurs habits ecclésiastiques ou leurs tenues tribales
affirmant un même message.
Nous sommes tellement connectés que nous devons traiter chacun
comme si une action envers l'autre était une action envers soi-même.
Encore une image pendant que je continue à penser de l'église Riverside.
9/11. La nuit dernière à "Chagrin Fall",
un journaliste et un présentateur TV ont dit,
ce soir, pendant qu'un service était tenu à l'église de Riverside,
que nous avons continué à la gare de notre ville.
"C'était," il a dit, "Un des moments les plus fort de toute ma vie."
On était tous entrain de souffrir,
mais vous avez invité les représentants de toutes les traditions à venir,
vous les avez invités tous.
Afin de trouver dans chaque tradition
ce qui nous dit comment réagir quand nous avons été humilié,
quand nous avons été méprisé et rejeté.
Ils ont tous parlé de leur propre tradition, ils ont eu un mot
à propos de la puissance curative de la solidarité, un avec l'autre.
Aujourd'hui la compassion est devenue une sorte de seconde nature chez moi
je suis devenu pasteur.
Maintenant, comme pasteur, j'ai un travail. Je dois prêcher des trucs,
mais je dois aussi donner l'exemple.
Or qui était le Père Divine à Harlem disait aux gens,
"Certaines personnes prêchent le Gospel.
Moi, je dois le rendre tangible."
Donc, le vrai problème c'est: Comment rendre la compassion tangible?
Comment en faire une réalité?
Ma foi a continuellement amélioré mon idéal,
et m'a poussé quand je me laissais aller.
Dans ma tradition, il y a un cadeau que nous avons donné aux autres traditions,
tout le monde autour du monde connait l'histoire du bon samaritain.
La plupart des gens pensent en termes de charité,
d'actes spontanés de gentillesse.
Mais pour ceux qui étudient ce teste un peut plus à fond,
vous allez découvrir la question profonde
qui amène à cette parabole.
La question est: Quel est le plus important des commandements ?
Et, selon Jésus, la réponse vient d'elle même,
"Vous devez vous aimez,
vous devez aimez votre seigneur Dieu avec tout votre cœur, esprit et âme,
et votre voisin comme vous même."
Et puis une personne a demandé, "Bon, qu'est ce que vous voulez dire, par voisin?"
Et il a répondu en racontant l'histoire de l'homme qui tomba au milieu des voleurs,
et comment les autorités religieuses ont tourné le dos,
et comment leurs supporters dans la congrégation ont tourné le dos,
alors que seule la personne dont on se méfiait, que l'on méprisait, arriva,
vit l'homme dans le besoin,
le soigna avec de l'huile et du vin,
le mis sur son propre moyen de transport,
et l'amena à l'auberge
où il demanda à l'aubergiste, "Prend soin de lui."
Et il dit, "Voici, un investissement initial,
mais si il a d'autres nécessités, fournis les lui.
Et pour tout ce qui sera nécessaire, je paierais à mon retour."
Ceci m'a toujours semblé être le sens
profond de ce que veut dire être un bon samaritain.
Un bon samaritain n'est pas simplement une personne dont le cœur a été touché,
par un acte immédiat de charité et de soins,
mais quelqu'un qui fournis un système de soins constant -- J'aime ça --
un système de soins constant à l'auberge ; prendre soin.
Je pense que c'est peut être la seule fois que la Bible parle d'un système de soins
et d'un engagement à faire tout ce qui est nécessaire,
pour que tous les enfants de Dieux aient leurs besoins satisfaits,
afin que nous puissions répondre quand maman pose l'éternelle question, "A propos de la santé,
est ce que tous les enfants sont là?" Et on pourra enfin dire oui.
Oh, quelle joie ça a été d'être une personne cherchant à rendre la compassion plus tangible.
Je me souviens de mon travail comme pasteur
ça a toujours impliqué de prendre soins de leurs besoins spirituels,
être préoccupé du logement, des soins médicaux,
pour les prisonniers, pour les infirmes, pour les enfants,
même l'accueil des enfants pour qui personne ne peut garder une trace
d'où ils viennent et où ils vont.
Être un pasteur c'est s'occuper des besoins de ces individus.
Mais maintenant, pour être un bon samaritain, et je dis toujours,
et pour être un bon américain, pour moi,
c'est pas simplement de me féliciter pour les soins que je procure,
la compassion prend une dynamique d'entreprise.
Je crois que ce qui ce faisait autour de la table à Bloodworth Street,
dois être fait autour des tables dans les rituels de foi
jusqu'à ce qu'on devienne une famille, cette famille ensemble,
afin que nous comprenions la nature de notre unité.
Ensemble nous ne sommes qu'une seule personne.
Donc, laissez moi vous expliquer ce que je veux dire quand je parle de compassion,
et pourquoi je pense que c'est tellement important qu'à ce moment de l'histoire
on ait décidé d'établir une charte de la compassion.
C'est important car c'est est une période spéciale de l'histoire.
C'est le moment qui, bibliquement, on en parlera comme
du jour, ou de l'année, des faveurs divines.
Ceci est une saison de grâce.
Des choses inhabituelle sont entrain de se passer.
Merci de m'excuser, comme homme noir, de célébrer,
l'élection d'Obama comme un signe inhabituel
du fait que c'est une année divine,
et pourtant, il y a tellement besoin de faire plus.
Nous avons besoin d'apporter des soins, de la nourriture et de l'éducation
ainsi que du respect pour les citoyens de Dieu, pour tout les enfants de Dieu,
et de se souvenir de l'éternelle maman.
Maintenant, laissez moi finir mon discours en vous disant
que quand je ressens quelque chose de très profond,
ça prend normalement la forme d'un verset.
Et donc je veux finir avec une petite chanson.
Je vais finir avec cette chanson -- c'est une chanson enfantine --
car nous sommes tous des enfants à la table de l'éternelle maman.
Et si l'éternelle maman nous a appris correctement,
cette chanson va avoir du sens, pas seulement pour ceux d'entre nous qui font partie de cette assemblée,
mais à tout ceux qui ont signé la charte de la compassion.
Et ceci c'est pourquoi nous le faisons.